the Joe Rogan experience what kind of
music did you guys play in the very
beginning well when I started I was
living in New York City and when my
first band White Zombie started I was
working at pee-wee's Playhouse actually
as a production assistant for people oh
yeah
first season did you know Phil Hartman I
know I was a production assistant did
you see him
I saw people aren't cuz it's Phil
Hartman and it was Paul rooms obviously
it was William Marshall who played
Blacula he was the cartoon King at that
point there's all these great people
Larry Fishburne was cowboy Curtis that's
trying to think who else was there wow I
forgot he was on it the only interaction
I ever had with anybody was Paul Reubens
and I was staying in there and he walked
by he goes where's the bathroom it's
right there that's it that's that was it
so I figured oh it's crazy that white
zombie was your first band - yeah and
one of the odds it was weird because we
didn't play any covers and we sort of
nobody really knew how to play when we
start and we sort of invented it sound
based upon completely not knowing what
you're doing really yeah because yeah
that's like any band like The Ramones
it's like well we know these three
chords but we understand they
instinctively understand catchy pop
songs even though it doesn't make sense
because when you try to learn a Ramone
song it doesn't make sense even though
it seems like all these really simple
songs because I've played them before
because I've done this Ramones tribute
thing I go verse-chorus wait verse again
two courses that are not like they're so
catchy but the structure is so odd
because you could tell they were just
sort of inventing this thing they're
doing and that's how I felt with us
because I had this weird idea like let's
never play conventional drum beats which
is like saying let's never make the song
fun for anyone to listen to I got over
that but but it just yeah you just I
don't know talking about did you take
any classes in the early days or did you
just
well I went to New York originally got a
Parsons School of Design for fine arts
but I got kicked out because my grades
dropped to low because I went from
Haverhill to New York so I was like I'm
just hanging out dance at Arial all
night I'm not going to school because
dance Adaro is amazing because one night
it would be
you know brendi MC like before anyone
knew who they were and then it would be
like Nick Cave then it'd be this was
like I was i stayed that every night
till 4:00 a.m. and then would go to
school and just you know fall asleep or
fall asleep on the train ride home in
new jersey then try to get back so you
never went to school like like for
classical musical instruments or
anything no and everyone I I can't learn
anything I'm think I'm incapable I just
have to do it and figure it out and do
it wrong a thousand times I can't I just
incapable even when I was a little kid
if we got a game I was incapable of
reading the directions we would just
let's just make up our own rules
we got a spinner and these little guys
let's just you know it was like three
lines of directions to learn how to play
the Happy Days game we wouldn't bother
you're giving so many kids out there
hope right now listening to this they're
like that's me yeah I mean if you can
make it you can be you could be Rob
Zombie can be an idiot and make it I
mean I remember when I got kicked out of
school I was sitting in New Jersey I was
probably 19 maybe 20 and I was just
sitting there thinking well I did it I'm
a [ __ ] loser because I had you know I
was making like a hundred bucks a week I
got kicked out of school I'm sitting
there in this crappy ghetto neighborhood
in Jersey City here's two of my life it
worked out yeah it worked out somehow
isn't that crazy
just things just eventually get better
yeah yeah oh and you I don't know how I
guess I don't know how because it never
they would never seemed like it was
going to like white zombie was a band it
seemed like everyone hated and no matter
what we had to be literally the last
band in New York City to get a record
deal maybe that's why we got it like
literally out of bands we have to sign
them but even when that happened there
was always this weird thing and maybe
you could relate we got it offered a
record deal with RCA Records now we're a
band that hasn't got anything and I was
like man it doesn't seem right I turned
it down and then we got MCA and I turned
it down was like I think we should wait
hold out for Geffen Records now that we
have nothing this is people holding out
for Geffen Records because they were the
biggest at the time
with no reason to be holding out but we
got signed to Geffen eventually do you
have those kind of balls cuz that seems
like you well I think it's balls mixed
with stupidity at the same time because
I I know I could be my own worst enemy
because you want to sign the Geffen you
know I come up with an album title
they're like really you're gonna call it
less Exorcist Oh devil music vol 1 is
this just to guarantee we don't get any
good placement on the album in stores I
guess and then the like well we're gonna
hi let's hire so-and-so to direct a
video tag naming you know he just did
the naming some bait the Whitesnake
video all right now I'm gonna do it but
it all worked it's crazy though that you
passed on to legitimate record companies
I wouldn't mean most kids when they're
starting out or so you know you're like
holy [ __ ] this is our chance I didn't
think they were good enough you know we
weren't good enough for anything either
I don't know what that thought was well
maybe you just I'm not a believer in
fate but it kind of seems to fall into
place for you it yeah I don't know it's
like I feel like my whole life is just
like I could have gotten hit by that car
I just didn't yeah cuz I just stopped
one second short from actually stepping
in front of a speeding car and made it
so you always wanted to make movies
though that was always some that was
always the thing I wanted to do for sure
but that seemed completely undoable
because it was just like Hollywood and
movies I mean it just it feels so far
far removed I mean living on the Lower
East Side playing CBGB's like and being
broke that seems doable like right you
know and that actually inspired me
there's I would see so many bands like
oh well they suck I mean we but at least
better than they are you know that was I
guess the motivation I had but Mike
movies just seem like no way that works
for comics too that's one of the best
thing Richard Jeni once said that about
open mic nights that really bad
comedians are great because they inspire
people to try it yeah yeah yeah I get I
because this is such a room Courtley I
think I have so many friends that are
comics that I've always become good
friends with over the years and I think
it's so similar
I can't imagine staying there trying to
tell jokes
people are laughing but I also can't
imagine staying there playing songs that
nobody wants to hear and they're just
looking at you like yeah yeah kind of
similar well the thing is I think it's
probably even harder maybe with songs
that nobody knows because people will
listen to jokes because they make them
laugh but songs that goes in a band that
no one knows like man you got to figure
out a way to rope these people in yeah
that's why I always figured like I was
always visually oriented so I always
would made sure the band had a look a
certain way in act a certain way the way
I wanted them to be you know so I
thought at least there's that at least
you can go this is awful but look at
these maniacs where you know everybody's
hair is down here and they're going
crazy and no one else is going crazy in
the club but they are at least it's you
know an entertaining trainwreck to watch
at least you know
[Applause]